these are members of Venezuela's
opposition they met at the Catholic
University in Caracas to debate ahead of
the primary elections in October
Maria Corina Machado has been leading
the polls but she was disqualified from
running for office last month
there is no possibility that the regime
today will hand over power to earn it
you have to earn it by force on October
22nd that's the Catalyst of strength of
Hope and unprecedented organization to
start to break down barrier by barrier
this dictatorship
[Applause]
the opposition in Venezuela had
previously relied on the creation of a
parallel government led by Juan guaido
to challenge president Nicola Maduro
but that strategy failed that's why
choosing one candidate to run against
Maduro in next year's presidential
elections is crucial to continue what
they call is their fight for democracy
Enrique capriles is one of the
candidates seeking support he told Al
Jazeera the biggest challenge is to
remain United
I have been disqualified and Maduro will
do the same to others but I think Maduro
will never be able to disqualify 28
million people the great test for the
opposition is that we know how to read
what's happening we know how to have a
plan for what's happening and know how
to execute that planning more beyond the
legitimate aspirations that any of us
may have let us think of our country
nearly 65 percent of people in Venezuela
live in poverty and the government has
been trying to recover from an economic
crisis that has forced Millions to flee
last month the government controlled
National Assembly announced it will
replace the Electoral Council after the
opposition saw its help in holding the
primaries annalize the Maduro government
will do everything possible to prevent
the opposition from joining forces the
government's strategy is to divide and
conquer the government is a minority
right now with only 20 support and the
country that wants change is around 80
percent and that's why they will do
everything possible as they always have
to keep the opposition divided as the
opposition Representatives debate
strategies to defeat Nicola Maduro
they're aware it's a difficult fight and
finding a common ground is the first Big
Challenge
a
[Applause]
well Guatemala's electoral court on